All right, this is always a very comforting verse for me on a first Peter in this, we
should greatly rejoice though, now for a little while, if need be, we have been
grieved by various trials. We all go through various trials that the genuidus,
genuidus of our faith feed more precious than gold that perishes though. It is
tested by fire, may we fall to praise honor and glory at the revelation of Jesus Christ.
Our whole life is to break your glory even in our difficult circumstances. We go
through various trials, intribulations, and struggles, and pains, and hurts, and
difficulties. We always need to go back to have it drive us to him.
It drive us to a deeper relationship with him. That's what's going to bring him
going already. Okay, so reminder to everybody between visits to check our blog, and
remember to check the member site for any new updates. So on the member site for
updates, we'll have these updates. So this I just took a screenshot of today's
member site, what's the new updates? So number one, use the members only site to
see all announcements. You already know that. But here's the newest update. All full
patients, that's you have reaccess to all our new courses. All new patients, all of
our patients have free access to all our new courses. And if you don't know what our
courses are, these are what our courses are. I can put a screenshot of our courses so
that you can see them. If you haven't looked at them yet, I'll put them up right here.
There's our new courses. So you can go on our main website, and you'll see on the
top it says courses. And click on that. And you'll see these courses. You should be
able to access the course. Your login to the course is the same login that you're using
the username and password that you do to login to this to the members only site. So the
username and password, which the username is your main email. And the password is what
you created that username, that password, should log you into all these courses. So we have
another course that will be published probably by middle end of next weeks. That's called
the Read Your Genes course. That's all on genetics. And then it about a mug will have my course on
mushrooms up. So we have a lot of new courses, a lot of new content. We're trying to give you as much
education as possible. These all these courses are $697. They're free to you. So you have free
access to these courses. You want to dive into deeper depths of knowledge of these different things.
Then you can utilize to access that course. We have family members that have product live,
and you want to learn more about it. We've been access that course. Okay.
And then a couple of weeks ago, I put about 22 videos of the right page of the member site
as a whole bunch for Q&A on that. So make sure you check that out if you have questions about
your rights. You guys are off experts on the right. So you probably don't have that. And hopefully
you guys are getting on Mondays and Paul with Anne. So we didn't have a lot of questions that came in.
That's good news because hopefully you're getting your questions answered. But let's jump into the
four questions that we have. What treatments do you suggest for tumors that have broken through
the skin? Well, it depends on the tumor. So typically,
topical things like Blacksav are really good for certain types of cancer.
Specifically, Blacksav was originally formulated for skin cancers. And
most commonly for melanoma. Though we have people with squamous cell cancer that use it,
you really don't want to use Blacksav on basal cell cancer. But we're squamous cell and melanoma.
We had people use Blacksav for breast cancers that have broken through the surface. And
some other different cancers that have broken through the surface. There's just needs to be a lot
of precaution taken. And it's difficult to oversee the use of Blacksav with a person because Blacksav
can be extremely caustic. And it can draw cancer really strongly, which is a good thing. But the bad
thing is is that you really need somebody local to help support you to be able to actually visualize
it in person. Look at it, making sure that it's drawing the way we want it to draw on such. So
we do have some people with breast cancer that are using Blacksav, but most of them have a local
person that they're working with as well. So it's not just us that they're working with. Some
other cancers that have broken through the surface that are very large, you really can't use Blacksav.
Blacksav is typically recommended for no more than a dime or a quarter size in the cancer. So it's about
three centimeters of cancer at its greatest. It can cause a lot of pain. You might need pain medications
and so on your issues with it. So we don't recommend that. But you can certainly use a different
curcumin cream. There's just bunch of different stuff that you can try on a tumor that's broken
through the surface. And we have a lot of patients that are trying different things. So that's what we
recommend because every cancer is different and we're going to react differently. But that kind of
leads us to this next question about MMS. So what if anything have you heard about MMS master
mineral solution? The short name for that is MMS, or it's also called chlorine dioxide. That's the
typical term that they use for it now because MMS as a term, master's mineral mineral solutions as a
term that was coined by Mr. Hummel, I think his name is. And he had got a lot of
contrast. And in my opinion, rightfully so, because he was making claims that were outlandish and
irresponsible in my opinion. And it does not help your cause. I think even if you have a good
product, if you start claiming that it cures everything, it's the it's the panacea of all disease.
I just think that's wrong because there's there is no such thing. And when you start making those
kind of claims that he made at seminars, and you see this at some different multi-level marketing type
seminars situations where they make these outlandish claims that they can't back up
at all. And I'm not against using anecdotal information when you're talking about a possible solution
to the serious disease. I'm not against using products that maybe don't have double blind studies
done on them. I'm not against that at all, but you don't make claims. I mean, I love the right
machine, but I don't claim that cures anybody, or cures any disease. But you start doing that.
You should kind of get in trouble with my point of view. You don't mislead people.
That's what was happening with MMS. I have a lot of experience with MMS. That's with cancer. But
we used to see a lot of line patients years ago. I had a clinic up in Duluth, Minnesota,
and it was just a big, big area for Lyme disease. And MMS works really well to help kill
biotoxins like Lyme. It is a chlorine type solution. And that's where it gets its bad name.
Matter of fact, that's what somebody had recommended to President Trump at the time to use MMS.
When they explained it to him, I have no idea the details of this. But I think that's what he was
talking about. What he made some off the cup comment about drinking bleach to kill COVID.
That was complete misnomer and a misrepresentation of what MMS is. It's not bleach. It's chlorine
dioxide, and it's different than bleach solution. But it does have that bleachy smell,
because it's got the chlorine in it. And it was explained to him the way he understood it, and the way
he represented it in his comment made him look very foolish. He got a lot of backlash from it.
The sad thing is, is that MMS probably would have been a good solution for a person with COVID,
because I think where MMS shines is in treating a stubborn biotoxin. So a biotoxin is a
pathogen, a living organism, like Lyme disease, which is a bacteria, and it's co-infections,
which can be viruses, or like COVID, which is a virus, MMS could be a possible aid for that,
because it does kill directly. It doesn't kill by stimulating a immune response. It kills directly.
So for people, especially people with Lyme disease that have phase 3 line in an autoimmune
situation, where they don't want to do a lot of things that will stimulate an immune response,
which seems to be counter-intuitive if you have a pathogen, but when you also have an autoimmune
disease, if you stimulate a immune response to try to kill the pathogen, you will kill that which
you have antibodies against first, and you will kill self-tissue if you have an autoimmune disease.
So you have to be careful in a phase 3 line situation. There am I using something that will kill directly
like MMS. It doesn't stimulate an immune response, and it could help kill directly, and it could be a
real big aid. Now we don't see very many Lyme patients anymore. We just don't have time
to do full-line plans. It would be handling Lyme patients, one-on-one as much as we used to,
so we don't have MMS on our store. We took MMS off of our store. We used to sell it. We took
it off our store because it got so controversial. FDA was coming after anybody that was selling
the MMS, which is an absolute ridiculous thing because nobody could get hurt by anything, but you'd
have to try to be hurt by using MMS. But you could be hurt by taking an entire model of vitamin D,
I suppose, too. You could overdose on vitamin D. So you could get hurt by doing anything. But for the
FDA to spend time in taxpayer monies, to go after places that are selling product like MMS
is absolutely ridiculous and criminal in itself when drug companies have to put 30 seconds of
disclaimer after a drug ad because actually the best studies that they picked out to get FDA approval
still showed people with those types of symptoms. You realize that when you see those drug ads,
and they go, they cause blah, blah, blah. 30 seconds of diseases that it might cause,
when they do studies, double-blind studies on drugs to see if they were, they literally will send it
out to maybe 50 universities to do the studies. They have to do a study and they list that they
have to have 100 people in the study or 1,000 people in the study, and they literally have to list
all the side effects of the people in the side of the double-blind that actually got the drug.
So, and then when they do those 50 studies, they may have had, they may have had 48 of the studies come
back where nobody got better from the drug. Everybody just had side effects. Well, they don't legally have
to publish those studies. But they have two studies that came back, one from Baylor and one from, you know,
Texas A&M that showed positive effects of that study. Well, they only publish those two studies
and then give that to the FDA. But they still have to by law list in their ads the side effects
that happened in those best two studies. And that's what you're hearing when they're reading off
those side effects. So, can you imagine if they had to read off the side effects of everything
all this negatives from all the bad studies that they even, they were so bad that they didn't even want
to publish. That's how this, that's how corrupt the FDA and the drug industry is. And then they go
after somebody because one person complained they got a headache from taking MMS. It's just absolutely
might not be. There are MMS protocols for cancer. It's fairly high dose MMS. I cannot see how taking MMS
orally would really help anybody with cancer just can't wrap my head around the physiology of that.
But I can see the possibility of doing MMS topically for cancer. More might help. I don't know. It certainly
could help. I can't even imagine how a chloride solution in the bloodstream would help kill cancer.
But I do think that there's a possibility, but I think it'd be a minute possibility for a
topical cancer. So, this would not be something that I would recommend necessarily high on the list.
But if we couldn't find anything else, it's certainly worth trying. Because every cancer is
different. Remember that if you have a topical cancer or something that's broken through the surface,
there's no harm, no foul in trying different things. And if I was in that situation, I would try to
use as much logic as possible and knowledge as possible, but I would be trying different things.
DMSO was talked about in this too. DMSO can be used and added with MMS can be added to an MMS topical
solution, but could be used by itself. DMSO is di mechal cell box side. It is a sulfur type
chemical. And it can be very anti-inflammatory. So, DMSO became very popular in the 1970s,
using it topically for shoulder injuries and joint problems and even spinal problems,
spinal neurological problems when the problem with the neurology at the spinal cord was inflammatory.
So, there was a inflammatory condition, even a car accident victim that damaged their spinal cord
paralyzed. There are case studies where using DMSO over the spinal cord decreased the inflammation
and that person was able to walk again to some degree. So, DMSO is a very powerful anti-inflammatory.
It absorbs like instantly. So, DMSO is used with a lot of other things to help draw things into
the tissues. So, using DMSO, we use DMSO in our homemade curfewin cream. DMSO can be used in a
spray bottle. DMSO is like water, liquid like water, but it has some negatives. You'll get
it smells very garlicky. You'll get a garlic taste in your mouth. You'll get a garlic smell because
it's the sulfur and an oyster taste in your mouth after using it, which some people don't like,
but if it does help them with their chronic rheumatoid arthritis or something else, it can be
beneficial. So, you can use it as a drawing agent because it absorbs so quickly. So, if I want to get
turmeric into a cancer that's maybe a centimeter deep, I can use turmeric surfacedly and then spray
some DMSO over the top of it. So, you could use DMSO to draw other things into the tissue,
but you have to understand that and be careful. You can't put a chemical lotion on like something
like over-the-counter lotion that has a whole bunch of crappy chemicals in it and then spray
DMSO in it. You'll drive those chemicals into your bloodstream too. That's not necessarily good.
So, you shouldn't be using those crappy chemical oceans anyhow, but for a person that isn't
as naturally minded as you guys are, they could possibly toxify themselves by using DMSO because
it will draw anything in. So, you want to make sure your skin is clean or then put whatever you want
to get into your body on your skin and then you can spray some DMSO over the top of it. It's a great
solution. You can buy it on Amazon. It's very inexpensive and that wouldn't be something that you
could try by itself on a topical open cancer. And there really isn't any harm in DMSO. You can't
really hurt yourself with DMSO. So, it's another thing that you could use. Why is bone brought
not good for me the cancer that I have? So, bone broth is let's define what bone broth is. So,
bone broth was first really came into use about 10, 12 years ago with some certain diets to help
heal the gut. So, bone broth here is how you make bone broth. If you're going to make your own
bone broth is that you take some beef bones or some chicken bones and you cook it in water
on low for a couple days. Some people did this in their crock pot on low or even on high
in the crock pot. So, it's like at a slow boil and you're basically trying to get all the nutrients
out of the bone itself. Why? Well, the reason is that bone broth contains a very high
quantity of glutamate. So, bone broth takes carries a high quantity of glutamate. So, remember what
glutamate is. So, glutamate is an amino acid. So, glutamate is an amino acid. So, amino acids make
up proteins. So, chain of amino acids equals a protein. Well, glutamate is a specific amino acid that
comes from protein. It's very high in animal proteins and it is high in bones. So, if you boil
bones and you make your own bone broth, you'll have a lot of glutamate. Why is that good? Why was that
a big craze to use bone broth? Well, especially when you're doing gut healing protocols, you have gut
issues. Glutamine, remember, we talked about this a lot. So, sorry for those that know this already.
Glutamine helps stimulate growth. And if you're trying to heal your gut, your gut cells,
your epithelial lining of your gut really feeds off of the glutamine. And we're trying to heal our
gut. We're trying to grow new gut cells and an excess amount of glutamate in our gut will help
increase the rate of replication of the epithelial cells. Well, that sounds like a great thing if
you want to heal your gut. But, that is never a good thing if you have cancer. So, if you have cancer,
you do not want to feed your body excess amounts of glutamate. Whenever I said glutamate is an
amino acid, it will be there is going to be some glutamate in all proteins. Even plant-based proteins
will have glutamate. But, animal-based proteins, meat and bones will have a much higher concentration
of glutamine. So, that's why people that especially people that their cancers are feeding more
off of glutamine or people that have cancers that are epithelial-based, that it's not a good idea
to be using any excess glutamine. Where would you get excess glutamine? In using bone broth,
in using protocols that were gut-healing protocols. In using different supplements that have
glutamated it. Why would a supplement have glutamated it? Because it's typically a gut-healing
supplement. So, a lot of the gut-healing powders that you would use to help heal your gut have glutamated
are clear GI has glutamate. But I actually picked clear GI and used that one as our product for
gut-healing because it has a fairly low amount of glutamate compared to some other gut-healing protocols.
Some gut-healing protocols have four to five grams of glutamate per serving, super high amount of glutamate.
Now, let me just find if you don't have cancer or you absolutely positively, though, you don't
have cancer. And you have major gut-product problems you want to heal your gut. There's nothing wrong
with doing that on a short-term basis. I still wouldn't do it on a long-term basis because you don't
know if you have cancer cells growing in your body. You certainly don't want to feed them and have
that be an issue. So, the other negative glutamate is glutamate, especially for those who have
the certain G-U-T-G defects, these G-L-U-T-G defects, I think it is. You could
glutamate the amino acid to glutamate. Glutamate is a neurotransmitter, functions as a neurotransmitter
of your body. And if you convert glutamate to glutamate more quickly because you have that
specific G-D defect, then that can be a problem. So, we talked about this just a couple weeks ago,
I think, I remember correctly, and that could be a major issue with people that have ADD-HD,
anxiety, OCD issues. So, you need glutamates in your body. Glutamates as a function, as an
excitatory neurotransmitter of your brain, they help wake you up in the morning, they help get you going
people that are exceptionally intelligent, have been shown to have kind of excess glutamates,
they tend to be more OCD type people. But they tend to also be very driven. So, there's nothing
wrong with glutamate. But too much glutamate could make you more wired, can make you not be able to
fall asleep, can make you full of anxiety, can make you, you know, unhealthy OCD, and even disorganized,
and then you don't become a person that is, you know, accomplishes a lot of life. So,
if that, if you kind of fall into that category emotionally, and anxiety is, you know,
would be something that you would categorize yourself in, I would say it might, it might serve you,
even if you didn't know anything about your genetics at that point, to decrease your animal proteins
and see if that would help, because you may have an excess amount of glutamate.
So, for cancer, glutamine can feed cancers, glutamine increases the rate of cell growth, glutamine
increases growth potential in cancer, glutamine also converts to glutamates, which is not good for
brain cancer, also, which I mentioned, and certainly not good for other emotional issues.
So, I'm not against animal proteins, but we tend to eat way too much animal proteins
at our society, and we might be better served by looking at more plant-based sources as well.
Question about sonnas. What are good sonnas? What are bad sonnas? What are our choices?
So, you guys know I'm very big on sonnas, and I think sonnas are a fantastic way to take pressure
off of your liver and your kidneys, because you're using your skin as a portal of detoxification.
So, anything you can do to help take pressure off your liver and your kidneys and your colon,
the better off you're going to be. So, it is also served for a cancer patient to possibly raise your
temperature up a little bit, which can kill cancer cells directly. So, sonnas have multiple functions.
Now, these two sonnas are the two sonnas that we sell in our store. Some people love these,
some people hate them. These are the ones that you sit in and your head comes out to this top of the
sauna. This one here is the one I personally have at home. We used to only have these sonnas.
The price of these went up to about $1,500, though. This is the Thurosage sonna, which we just started
carry, which I think is possibly even a better sonna, and it's less expensive. I think there's
some better quality materials in this sonna, though I've had no trouble with this sonna, and I really
like it. This Thurosage sonna is, I don't think it heats up quite as fast, but I think it's probably
a little better quality, and it is, I think, $300 less expensive, too. So, I like the ones
that your head sticks out personally, because I'm not dealing with cancer, the neck, or above. So,
I don't need to heat up anything higher than my neck, and I don't feel claustrophobic at all
this sonna. With my sinus condition, if I sit in a full wooden sonnas that step together that you
can buy, I feel like you can't breathe, and I just can't stay in there as long. These ones I can stay
in there longer, but heats up much faster. So, the wooden ones that step together, the positives of
those is that your entire body is in there, and you sweat a lot from your head, so you'll start sweating
from your head, and there can be some benefits from that, too. So, there can be benefits from the
wooden ones that you get into, that you turn on. The negatives of those is that you are getting some
gas off-gassing of the wood itself. Well, it's a cedar one. Well, I know, but that cedar off-gassing
isn't necessarily good for you. So, that is a possible negativity of the wooden sonnas.
Secondly, it takes a little bit longer to heat up, but think it takes 10 or 15 minutes for it to
heat up for you to go in there. These ones literally heat up in 30 seconds. You turn it on, you climb in
there, and you zip it up, and at about 30 seconds, the light is heated up, and you are cooking.
All any sonna, you always start. So, the other question is people ask, well, how long should I
do sonnas? How frequent should I do sonnas? You could do sonnas daily once a day, and the maximum
is 30 minutes. Now, not very many people, you might, somebody might, others call, might be in the
category, but not very many people consider the sonna for 30 minutes every day. Personally, the maximum
I got up to is, I think, 25 minutes when I was doing, and I do them in the winter, I don't do them in
the summer, but when I start again this fall, I'll probably be able to get there about 10 to 12
minutes, and I like, I got to get out of here, and I'll zip it again up. So, if, and then you work
your way up, and I do not do them every day, if you did them a couple times a week, that would be good.
Somebody said, you can't see my screen. Do you lose our screenshot here? I don't think so.
Says, we're still screen cherry. I don't know, I'm sorry. So, if you do search on our store,
for sodas, these, the, the ones that we're talking about are the only two that you will find.
So, these are the ones that zip up. Your head is exposed. The pros of that is you can still,
you're not breathing air that you're sweating into. You are not taking time for it to heat up.
You're not getting claustrophobic in the soda. In it, the other side, the other positive is that it
doesn't take as much space up. The wooden step together ones are more expensive, but there's some
benefits, having your whole body in it, and you're sweating from your head. The negatives, it
takes a longer to heat up. So, there's pros and cons to all of them. Some people like to sort of with
their, with their spouse or family members, and then you have to go with the, the wooden ones. They
make four person sodas or larger. Back to use, no more than 30 minutes a day, but typically if you're
going to do it daily, you're doing it less than that. Typically, the temperature is set at 140,
and typically, you're doing it a few times a week. If you're doing it every day and you're sweating
like a pig, then you may want to make sure you consider you may be taking extra scoop of greens,
or take some minerals, magnesium, because you will lose some minerals by sweating as well,
and you don't want to end up with my crypts or something like that. So, make sure you're not
demiteralizing yourself too much by doing too much soda. Just like I've said in the summer,
when I about work it outside and sweat like a pig, I might take some extra minerals, certainly some
magnesium. Well, that's all the questions that we had come in. Somebody asked a question. Do you
test for cell cores, myotoxin, and heavy metal, HMET, yes, those are two products that we use. Yes,
Swinking. My C8 IT numbers continue to drop, but my tumor size seems to remain the same. Can you help
explain the reason behind this and what to look for? I've been reading about other alternative
treatments for paedcreatic cancer, specifically in terms of paedcreatic cancer. Can you please speak
a little on the following? Low dose, no. Trexone, life one, allergic acid. Okay, so remember, the
definition of cancer is cells that are in rapid replication. Definition of cancer is cells that
are in rapid replication. If your cells are in rapid replication, then the tumor will be getting
larger over a period of time. And it will get larger over a period of time depending on the
rate of rapid replication. So if it's a more aggressive cancer, it's going to get large,
it's going to see major changes in size over a period of a month. If it's a little bit less
aggressive cancer, you may see just slight changes in a three month period. But if you're looking at
a CT scan or MRI that's comparing apples to apples over a month or two or three months period,
and the tumor's not getting any larger, then you have to say that the cancer is dramatically
slowed the rate of replication because there is some apoptosis taking place. So there is still
some replication taking place, but if it's not getting any bigger, it's not acting as cancer anymore.
So if it's not acting as cancer, meaning in a state of rapid replication, that's a very good thing.
And if that's true, then it's not uncommon that your CA 19 numbers would drop or any other tumor
markers may drop too. But everybody wants this cancer to go away. So this mass is three centimeters
wrong. And it's still three centimeters wrong. It's still there. There's a really good chance.
How does the cancer go away? It doesn't just disappear magically. The cells have to go through
some rate of cell death to have the mass go down. And the rate of cell death
has to be greater than the rate of cell replication. So normally, the reason why after you're at adult,
your finger doesn't get bigger when you're, is it any bigger when you're 50 years old that it was
when you're 30 years old is because the rate of cell replication is equal to the rate of cell death
or apoptosis. It's not getting any larger. So same thing with a cancer. If it's not getting any
larger, then the rate of apoptosis is equivalent to the rate of replication, meaning it's not even
acting as a cancer anymore. So it's fallen off the definition of cancer. Is it still a cancerous
tumor that's there? Yes. Is it acting like a aggressive cancer anymore? No. Will it ever disappear?
Quite possibly no. The only thing that will cause it to disappear is that if your rate of cell death
greatly exceeds the rate of replication, even normal rate of replication. That's why chemotherapy
tends to shrink tumors because it's very caustic. It's very poisonous, and it will kill the cancer
cells. So you don't get apoptosis, which is normal programed recycling of normal cell death taking place.
You get cell lysis, which is a pathological cell death, which I guess that's not bad when you're
talking about cancer. We don't want it to be there. So we don't care if it pathologically dies,
but it's not necessarily necessary unless the cancer is in a spot and the size of it is
impeding physiological function of something. It's pressing out an artery or it's pinching a nerve
or something like that. It's not impeding physiological function. Let's say the cancer is in
your pain-creous, and it's not impeding physical function. It's not causing you any symptoms,
but it's still three centimeters around. Do we care if it stays three centimeters around for the next
40 years? I hope you don't. I mean, if you're obsessive, compulsive about having it begun,
you could make some great mistakes and do things that could damage other healthy cells in order for
you to be satisfied with it being gone. But if you were just satisfied with it, not being
growing like a cancer by definition, you could live a normal, healthy, physiological life. And that's
what we have to kind of change our focus on. So if our tumor markers are dropping and the cancer
is not replicating faster than it's died, therefore it's staying the same size. We should be rejoicing.
So is there anything wrong with trying other things? No, no, but I would not try them in lieu of what
you're currently doing because whatever you're currently doing, it must be working. So, and I'm not
saying it's the right and the supplements, maybe it was the chemo. I don't know, but whatever it is that
you were doing, and I have been doing is working to slow this growth. Now, come at it on some of these
things. Low dose, no traction has been cited as something that can be good for cancer patients. Low
no traction at 50 milligrams was a medication that was used to help get people off of morphine and
some other addictive substances. But at low dose, it was found to help be an immune system
modulator. So it can help calm an overactive immune system. It can help stimulate an underactive
immune system. Now, theoretically, that can be good for cancer if the person's immune system is
so suppressed that they need that stimulation if they're really ill. But someone who's that in
that state, which I, which you are not, I don't think low dose, no traction would be a wise decision.
That's just my opinion. Low dose, no traction is more aptly used in autoimmune conditions when people
have a hyper-functioning immune response that's causing a huge inflammatory response, let's say in
rheumatoid arthritis, low dose, no traction, so it can help calm that down. Algiac acid is the main
constitute of that is pulmonary granite that is in our phase two and pond one assist as well. But
that is a still a good product. And it's it really helps with phase two detoxification.
Life one I'm not familiar with. Seven, 14x I've read about but I can't really comment. I don't know
enough about it to comment on that. Can physical vibration of a cancerous tumor also help trigger the
immune system to attack the cancer? I thought of this based on the right frequency vibrates
of the tumor. Yeah, I think that's very possible. The only thing you'd have to be careful about with
physical vibration. We're talking with the right that is vibration at a cellular
point. If you did physical vibration like using a handheld vibrator over a pancreatic cancer,
you could irritate things as well. Though if you did it a little bit farther away, not directly
over it, it could help stimulate lymphatic flow. That's the idea of using like that that
the the bouncy thing that people bounce on for rebounder. Rebounder to get the lymphatic drainage
going. And there's benefits to that. So yes, I would just be careful directly over cancer with
that. I was thinking because I just did a three day motorcycle trip where the bike vibrates all day
long. We're on the road most of the day. And then afterwards I noticed some distinct differences
like a little bit more blood in my stool and other things. So it just struck me that maybe something
like that is happening. That's why I asked. Maybe. Yep. It's so I mean, you could just have some
physical irritation to that of that too. So I'm not saying that this is certainly always bad thing,
but you get some flow going with that. Thank you. Okay, fun on your motorcycle trip.
Blast had a blast. Wonderful. Pressure really makes a difference. Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I know our mind stays focused on I want this God. I see this a lot with with breast cancer
patients because they could feel the mass there. It's like I want they just want this God. Okay,
but it hasn't you know, if if it hasn't changed size in six months, you know, you know, by getting
it removed surgically, could you I mean, that's saying it's always wrong, but I'm saying, is there
a possibility that you're just making an angry and causing more damage than than than good because now
your body has to heal from a surgery and how does your body heal from surgery? It gives off a ton of
growth factor in order to heal that world. And you definitely know you have sarcian tumor cells in the
tissues. Could that be a piece of what could cause metastasis? And we know that metastasis is the
energy of all cancers. So anything we got to do to try to prevent metastasis the better. So
the tumor is blocking and tested. That is the colon cancer block in a tested neurocluded. Would you
want to reduce the size of the tumor? Yeah, because that's what I said. If it's affecting
function of physiology, then yes. But that's when you know surgery is you've got to start
considering that or if you have the tumor pressing under the artery and it's blocking flow to major
organ. And with pacreatic cancers, you could have blockage of the bile duct you have to put a
stint in or open it up. You've got to deal with the physiology there. But if the if the tumor,
if the cancer is in the liver, and it's not causing any physiological, you know major physiological change
because it's just space occupied lesion in the liver or in the breast or something like that, then
then you wouldn't be as concerned about reducing the size is getting it to stop growing.
And even if it is partially blocking the intestinal tract in the lumen in the intestine,
as long as you're having bowel movements regularly, and you're checking it on a regular basis to
make sure it's not getting any larger. Yeah, it can affect your lifestyle because you've got to make
sure that you'd ever get constipated and such because that could be a major problem. So yeah,
of course we always want the cancer to shrink. We always want it to disappear. But we got to stop
it from being, you know, rowing cancer first. And then hopefully we start going in that direction.
All right, I think we'll say goodbye for the night. I hope this is beneficial for everybody
and make sure you jump on next Monday's meeting with Anne and feel free to if you want to learn more
about different conditions and stuff. I think the detox course will be good for everybody.
Then let's stop by the kids course. You have all the stuff already in the member site. That's not
necessary. But the detox course might be beneficial. Oh, and we got the rife course, the frequency
healing course. That is, if you ever have any issues with the rife, make sure that you're talking
about these courses. If you jumped on late, you guys have access to all our courses. We'll have
the genetics course right here and we'll have the mushroom course in about a month. Genetics
course should be up by the end of next week, possibly. So the frequency healing course is all about the
rife. So if you have questions about the rife, there's more information in there. As probably don't
have any questions, there's lots of rife. There's some newbies here. In the seventh phase of detox,
that can be beneficial just to learn more about detoxification. If you guys have free access to that,
these are all these courses are 700 dollars or just other 700 dollars because you guys
free access to that. So make sure you use that if you want to. All right, goodbye everybody. Have a
blessed Wednesday and I will see you in a week and we'll see you on Monday. Bye-bye.